or during discuss a number of things
today former newspaper editor Emily
Sheffield conservative commentator
Esther kraku and Royal commentator
former press secretary for our late
great Queen Dickie Arbiter welcome to
all of you thank you Dicky let me start
with you 12 years you were the press
secretary for her majesty this must have
been for you personally a very long and
sad and reflective 10 days it was long
it was sad it was reflected I didn't
quite get my head around it until I saw
the hearse leaving Balmoral Castle and
then again it hit me when the RF
regiment pallbearers took it off the
C-17 at northold airport there were
several moments when I nearly lost it I
was working for an Australian Channel
and um uh Ali
sort of grabbed my hand at once
yeah she she grabbed my hand because she
saw that something was a foot and I'm
very grateful to her for having done
that and that was when the coffin was
being lowered into the raw
um Crypt Hudson George's yeah it was an
incredibly poignant moment I mean that
was the moment really I felt a finality
the final moment where we would ever see
this queen in any form it was our final
moment to say goodbye and thank you your
majesty would she have been surprised by
the sheer scale of outpouring of love
and affection probably yes because every
time there was a jubilee she's still on
that balcony and the crowd stretched all
the way from Buckingham Palace back to
Trafalgar Square it was huge a million
people and she never quite believed it I
mean it happened on her golden jubilee
her diamond and her platinum and it was
something that she really didn't believe
I mean she almost echoed the words of
her grandfather George V the people love
me and what came to mind while you were
while you were talking is that George V
was called grandpa England and I'd like
to think that late Queen was Grandma yes
absolutely
um Emily a lot of issues coming out of
all this one is this concept being put
out that Charles may want a sort of
downsized coronation
if that is true what is your view of
that
well I don't know what it's downsizing
from but I imagine in other words
compare it to the Queens it won't be as
lavish or ostentatious as the Queens
when she was coronated not not her
funeral
um again I'm not entirely sure how
lavish it was but I think we've done it
was pretty lavish well I think somewhere
yeah you saw it I saw it I think
somewhere in the middle you know look as
old as I know you are
um well it's interesting questions I
mean my gut feeling about this is if
you're going to have a monarchy do it
properly the great thing about the last
10 days was being able to show the world
that nobody has anything anywhere like
this so if you start downsizing
everything you kind of end up with a lot
of European monarchies when which it
becomes so downsized it becomes
pointless there are certain things in
the service you've got to have you've
got to have the anointing you've got to
have the crowning the crowning might not
be the same as Lake Queens where the
crown was some Edwards Crown was placed
on a head it might be raised over over
King Charles's head and then placed on a
cushion a symbolic crowning and there'll
be two crownings because Camilla will be
crowned the queen console she will be
crowned the queen concert you don't
don't start chipping away at tradition
no I don't think so yeah the only thing
I would warn may be is when the queen
was coronated this was a young woman a
very good looking young woman who had it
the shock of her father's death meant
that she was suddenly escalated to her
role as running the monarchy head of the
monarchy Charles is not going to have
the same glamor but isn't that even more
reason to make it look as glamorous as
possible well yes make it look glamorous
but be careful you don't over primitive
okay let's move to another another
ongoing running saw Esther we've talked
about this many times Megan and Harry
can't be ignored again their friend Gail
King best friends with Oprah Winfrey who
of course actually was the enabler for a
lot of this stuff with that well
actually friends
well Gail and Oprah are great friends
yeah and the sussexes are neighbors of
Oprah so they sort of I think Megan's
hijacked them as friends as well and is
the point though Gayle King said on
American television this morning that
she believes nothing's really been
resolved let's take a look
big families always go through drama
always go through turmoil it remains to
be seen are they going to be drawn
closer together or are they going to be
drawn apart I have no idea I have no
inside information on that but I will
tell you this it was good to see Harry
standing with his family
I mean it was but I'm not sure anything
got resolved yeah I think it's too early
to tell I think obviously everyone is
waiting with basic breath over Harry's
book which I really hope
is not as sort of bombastic as we fear
it will be and obviously you know
Megan's podcast let's hope she doesn't
say anything more egregious family I
read today it's probably not true but it
was an interesting sort of take on it
that she's busy going through all the
podcasts and trying to remove anything
that attacks the monarchy because she
now knows how badly that would play the
problem they've got I think dick you in
this is that that's really their only
currency which is worth all the money
they don't have any other currency
they've already rubbished the royal
family and how you pull back from that I
really don't know you talk about
reconciliation there's a very wide Chasm
there isn't a bridge big enough to
bridge that Chasm and William I didn't
see William give Harry a single glance
the entire time they were seen in public
let alone Kate and and Megan it looked
at me like they were putting this show
on to to do it for their grandmother and
credit to them for being able to do that
but the enmity between them all is
incredibly real I mean it's not invented
by the media I do think that King
Charles and owns the Prince of Wales
have done the right thing which is to
put the Olive Branch out because they
need to be the grown-ups in the room
absolutely Megan and Harry like
bitching about the royal family they
need to they need to neutralize that and
they need to do it fast well they need
to shut up don't they I mean they just
need to they left the country in Duty
for free I think they've done so go and
have your freedom and privacy and shut
up I hope I do hope they do reconcile
because I think it'll be a positive
thing for every everyone I would advise
Megan and Harry to find some sort of
expertise like I don't know get a degree
in neurobiology or something because
when you're only around
neurobiology when your only relevance
stems from being in that royal family
with Megan's case for two years you you
kind of want a backup plan additionally
Megan is going to keep capitalizing on
what has been capitalizing also yeah
she's got a title she's got a captive
audience in the United States I mean her
the Sussex Squad were tweeting in
America but she was the only one no no
it's ridiculous um let's turn to
something happier because I find there's
a limited amount of time we can give
them before everyone's spleen start to
vent and the pallbearers sticky I found
it unbelief believably moving I've been
reading all about these ball bearers
young men the finest of this first
Battalion Grenadier guards were chosen
for this Duty and only especially from
Iraq thrown in from Iraq in many cases
many of them had done uh War tools and
so on but they were chosen I can't think
of a more pressurized thing
to do actually other than actually
engaging in real war than what these
guys did with it you're right there more
urgent water please for Champion
um
I can't think of a bigger honor for
these guys or a bigger responsibility or
more stressed to have a billion people
around the world watching as you are
carrying a very four billion well well I
I think I probably was an exaggeration
but the the relatives a lot and this is
a very heavy coffin and it's carrying
the greatest Monarch in history the
pressure not to make any mistake
enormous they were completely
Thoughtless and the country I think
recognized that my question is should
the country go further and recognize
them with with honors absolutely
absolutely
um you know honors have been given to
people for lesser things this was a
great moment it was a great moment in
their lives it was a great moment in our
lives and it was a great moment for the
royal family oh we all agreed on this
yeah absolutely we were just discussing
backstage weren't we whether it went MBE
Obe and youth or mbu I think as a start
it's an MBA I think they can lift up
eight MBS would be the least we can give
them and congratulations to them and to
their families it must have been
bursting but Pride but imagine being the
parent of one of those kids watching and
thinking please don't let anything go
wrong you're talking about the heavy the
heaviness of the coffin an American
tweeted me and said what are they making
so much fun they're only carrying a box
I tweeted back and said it's lead lined
yeah now go away oh exactly you get
idiots you should stay off Twitter
you're far too venerable for that kind
of behavior
it's great to see I wanted to catch up
with you because I'm sure you've been
through a lot of emotions in the last
couple of weeks and um it was a historic
moment I think the country did the queen
proud the country did the queen proud
the the people were magnificent there
was no angst in the queue not a few
celebrities allegedly jumping the queue
but they were they were all very
friendly they were all very relaxed when
somebody had to go out of the queue
perhaps to go to the new or be
interviewed on television they got their
place back in the queue there was no
squeezing you weren't impressed by the
cue jumpers no not particularly I
thought David Beckham was brilliant
queuing up for 14 hours yeah we won't
talk about the others